I think Sam knows where we're going.
We're going to look into the issue of
the son of man. Now, that played a a big
part and yeah, if you could put the clip
back up, brother. All authority has been
given to him. So, okay, let's go now.
Don't make me cry on that one. Don't
make me cry. Here by the fact that son
of man without the definite article is
just a way of saying human being. So,
there are some scholars such as Morris
Casey who believe that these son of man
sayings have been corrupted, at least
some of them, from originally saying a
son of man or the son of man in the
sense of just meaning a human being.
Now, why would that interpretation be
correct here? Because Jesus says firstly
when he's accused of breaking the
Sabbath, he says, "Well, David did the
same thing." Let me just pause for one
moment. Let me make clarification for
the audience. I don't want that point to
go by, not us to deal with it. There is
no such evidence of there being any
corruptions on the son of man sayings.
There's no such thing. And I can even
quote liberal scholars. The implication
is no, which means it can't just be God
who breaks the Sabbath. He then says
that the Sabbath was made for man,
humans, not humans or man for the
Sabbath. Therefore, he says the word is
therefore the son of man is lord of the
Sabbath. If the son of man in some
context just means a human being, that's
how early church fathers interpreted it.
For example, in fact, some of the early
church fathers translated the son of man
as the son of Mary because they thought
it was Jesus indicating that he was the
son of a human being. He's incorrect
there. Let me be very clear. Alo, what
did Before you correct, what did he say
about the last point? That was very bad
argument. He claims that there are early
fathers that translated son of man as
son of Mary. No, they are not. He is
wrong there. Now, translation and
interpretation are two different things.
Do they translated as son of man? Yes,
they do. Alex Okconor, you're wrong. Do
they then say that this son of man is
the son of Mary? Of course. Guess what,
Alex Okconor? That's because the son of
man is a divine figure. And that divine
figure is Emmanuel, God with us, born of
the holy virgin. That is why in the
context of talking about the son of man,
they then tell us he is the son of Mary.
But no, you're wrong, Alex. They do not
translate it from Daniel 7 as being the
son of Mary. You're incorrect there.
I've gone from the apostolic era all the
way to the medieval era just looking at
what the fathers have to say about
Christ and son of man. He's wrong on
that point. S the implication is no.
Which means it can't just and by the way
I rewind so we could hear that part
again. Be God who breaks the Sabbath. He
then says that the Sabbath was made for
man humans not humans or man for the
Sabbath.
Therefore, he says the word is
therefore the son of man is lord of the
sabbath. If the son of man in some
context just means a human being that's
how early church fathers interpreted it
for example in fact some of the no they
did not just a human being they did not
he is confusing he's confusing that for
uh where the bible talks about son of
man in terms of humans but clearly there
is a divine figure identified as the son
of man of Daniel 7 there's an enormous
difference there and Alex Okconor gets
that wrong and doesn't draw that
distinction the early church fathers
translated the son of man as the son of
Mary because they thought it was Jesus
indicating that he was the son of a
human being and he was only born of
Mary. Given that undertone for this
phrase, the son of man, how else can I
read this passage except Jesus saying,
"Yeah, I'm working on the Sabbath." So
did David and that wasn't wrong. The
Sabbath was made for mankind. Therefore,
mankind is Lord of the Sabbath. If it's
only God who can work on the Sabbath,
then why does Jesus appeal to David? You
caught that. Yeah. What a what a silly
leap in logic that is. A massive leap.
It's a terrible argument. Yes. Terrible
argument. And explain why. Did he finish
his point? He he that point is finished.
There'll be another point in a moment.
Yeah. Okay. Well, notice what he just
said. Because son of man can
refer to humanity in general. Well, let
me bring up the passage on that. Yeah.
Yep. Yeah. I know you got those
articles, brother. I've got slides in a
bit, but what I want to do with Mark 2
in particular, he's trying to deny Mark
2, Jesus claiming to be the divine son
of man. Yes. You caught it now. You
caught the the It's a bad argument,
right? It's really bad. Yeah. I'm going
to show why it's bad. Okay, let's first
look at the context. We're going to open
up Mark 2. All right, he went from
mankind being Lord of the Sabbath.
That's absolutely nonsensical because if
we go at his interpretation, that means
now mankind can redefine Sabbath
observance according to their whims and
desires, which would be an express
violation to what is stated in the law.
You make no sense, Alex. Because if we
take what you said, even the example of
David, which you butchered big time. I'm
open up Mark 2. I'm going to open up
Mark 2 because I'm going to come back
earlier to show you. Okay. So, he's
saying then he said to them, "The
Sabbath is made for man, not man for the
Sabbath. So, the son of man is Lord even
the Sabbath." What is his point? He's
saying Jesus quotes 1st Samuel 21. Yep.
where David was fleeing for his life
because Saul was threatening him and he
went to
Abiather in the days and it doesn't say
Ather Mark is quite clear quoting our
Lord accurately says in the days of
Abther the high priest because although
Abther became the prominent high
priest during David's rule it was his
father Ahim that was high priest and
Saul slaughtered him yep so I just want
to be clear
He says, "The bread of presence was only
lawful for the priests. And yet, when
David was fleeing with his soldiers, and
they were starving and hungry, the
priests gave him the bread." Mhm. So
that he wouldn't starve and die as
sustenance to flee from Saul's attempt
of murdering him. I don't know how he
took this to mean that David somehow had
authority to violate the Sabbath. No.
No, what Jesus is getting at is that the
letter of the law does not take
precedence over the spirit of the law.
Let me break it down. So, if we take a
little longer to unpack things, it's
because we have no choice. We have to
Jesus is saying is that God's purpose in
giving you the law, read Deuteronomy 30,
he wants you to live, not die. He wants
to bless you, not curse you. Yep. Our
Lord's point is if you make the law
cumbersome, burdensome, then you now
kill the spirit of the law because the
law was given to bring life, preserve
life, improve the quality of life, not
diminish life. Yep. You understand? So
what Jesus is saying is by your
traditions, you have now nullified the
spirit of law. By your traditions, these
things you've added. You've now killed
the spirit of the law, which was to
bring life, preserve life, heal the
broken, improve the quality of life. But
by your traditions, you've now made it a
burden and you made people's lives
miserable. Yep. And he goes, note that
this spirit was always operative during
the Old Testament. Why? Because if a
himch had followed the letter of the
law, he could not have given David bread
and would allow David to starve and
either die or Saul catch up to him, kill
him. But Aheimch knew that though the
letter says this bread is only for us,
the spirit of the law is in dire
circumstances. Yes. If I have to go
against the letter of the law to save a
life, I will save the life and go
against the letter of the law. That's
his point, brother. Brilliant point.
That's a brilliant point. Let me try and
uh break it down for the audience a
little bit more. Even though you did a
fantastic job there. Um to me when I
heard him make that argument I had to go
to the text cuz um I I thought it was a
very very bad one to try to argue that
Christ is in essence saying I'm like
David it's okay to bend the rules shows
he's missing the whole point entirely.
David as you point out pointed out was
acting in emergency and unlawfully
unlawfully for the time period. He was
hungry running for his life ate
consecrated bread reserved only for
priests. When Christ references this, he
is exposing the hypocrisy of the
Pharisees, demonstrating the human need
takes precedence over
legalism. Period. But then what does he
say? He never says, "I'm doing the same
thing as David." No, he didn't say like
David, I'm too doing something unlawful
because of hunger. No, he transitioned
from David to himself with a divine
claim that the son of man is lord of the
Sabbath. They're radically different,
aren't they, brother? Yeah. And that's
why I got to now hammer the next point
to show that what Christ is saying. Now,
let's go a little deeper, brethren.
Listen. Okay. He says, "One Sabbath,
Jesus was going through the grain
fields, and as his disciples walked
along, they began to pick some grain
seeds." here his followers were picking
right heads of grain to eat not Jesus
now watch now it's going to make sense
if we read contextually the Pharisees
said to him look why aren't they doing
what is unlawful on the Sabbath this is
where he now says number
one following the spirit of the law
takes precedence over the letter of the
law number two because I am the Lord of
the Sabbath I am the one who determines
whether what they did is a violation or
not. And I'm telling you there is no
violation. That's the context. That's
correct. You understand what he's saying
here? Yep. 100%. He's not saying mankind
is Lord of Sabbath. That's nonsense.
Because if we take Alex's
interpretation, that means a man at any
time can then determine that he can
violate the Sabbath because from his
interpretation, it's not really a
violation because he has authority to
define what working is. That's not the
point. Jesus is saying, "I the son of
man who stands in place of humanity and
represent them. I am the Lord of the
Sabbath. As such, I have the right to
define whether what my disciples did was
a violation or not because I define what
working is on this day, not your
traditions." And I'm letting you know
there is no violation because I, the
Lord of the Sabbath, allow this because
that's the spirit of the law. He turned
the argument upside down 100%. Because
as you pointed out right there, the
Sabbath in the Old Testament is God's
institution. Exodus 28-11, only God is
Lord of it. When Christ says he is Lord
of the Sabbath, he's not claiming kingly
authority along the lines of David. He's
claiming divine authority. There's a
massive difference. You've got David, a
man who bends to the law, and then
you've got Christ, one who commands it.
There is no comparison at all. I have to
be honest, brother. I thought it was a
bad argument. I didn't think it was good
at all. Yeah. Well, I mean, David could
have flatten them. But here again, to
prove the point, Leviticus 23:3, there
are six days when you may work, but the
seventh day is a day of Sabbath rest, a
day of sacred assembly. You are not to
do any work wherever you live. It is a
Sabbath to the Lord. Now, here is
Yahwah. He is the God of the Sabbath.
He's telling his people, "You can't
work." But then who defines what work
is? God does. He gave you the law. You
can't do this, you can't do that. You
can do this, you can't do that. But if
you do what I tell you you can't do,
you're in violation. And what happened
to Sabbath breakers? They were killed.
That's correct. Read verse 15. They were
killed. So what is the Lord saying? I am
the Lord of the Sabbath. meaning I am
the one who has the authority to define
what working is and what not working on
the Sabbath is. And I'm telling you what
my disciples did is no violation. Why?
It's my Sabbath. I own it and I stand in
place of mankind to tell them you can do
this, you can't do that. He flipped it
on and said, "Now, let me hammer the
point that the entire chapter is trying
to show Jesus's divine identity." That's
correct. I want to show you this, but
you need to listen. We'll repeat
ourselves two or three times. Go rewatch
because I want you to understand it's
the exact opposite of what Jesus is
doing. He's showing himself to be in the
place of God whereas his disciples are
in the place of David. 100%. In the
analogy, the disciples are in the place
of David. They no more violate the
Sabbath than David did. He's not saying
he's in the place of David. He's saying
my followers are in the place of David.
And that what they did no more violated
the Sabbath than when the high priest
gave to David the bread of the presence
violated the law. So, he's not putting
himself in David's role. He's putting
himself in the role of God who owns the
Sabbath and he defines what working is.
That's the first point. Everyone got it?
Second point. Second
point. If you want proof Jesus is
claiming to be God here, right? Mark
2:18. The entire t chapter, brethren,
the entire
chapter is about Mark setting forth
Christ as the divine human one, the
divine son of man. Here, let me give you
another proof here. Just go to Mark 218
and 20. Now, when John's disciples and
the Pharisees were fasting, some people
came and asked Jesus, "How is it that
John's disciples and the disciples of
the Pharisees are fasting, but yours are
not?" Jesus answered, "How can the
guests of the bridegroom right here?"
Who's the bridegroom? Watch. Fast while
he's with them. So why are my disciples
not fasting? Because the bridegroom is
with them. When the husband shows up,
it's time for feasting. Okay? Yep. They
cannot so long as they have him with
them. But the time will come when the
bridegroom will be taken from them. On
that day, they will fast. Now, anyone
knowing the Old Testament knows the
bridegroom of Israel is God. Yep. Now,
understand what Jesus said. You know why
my disciples aren't fasting? The husband
is here. The bridegroom is here. When he
shows up, it's feasting. It's a wedding
banquet. But when I'm taken away, that's
when you mourn and fast. But hold on,
Jesus. Your Jewish audience knows. And
you know, Israel's bridegroom is God,
not a creature. Right here, uh, just one
passage, Isaiah
54:5. For your maker is your husband.
The Lord
Almighty is his name. The Holy One of
Israel is your redeemer. He's called the
God of all the earth. So hold on, Jesus.
In the context, you said you're the
bridegroom to Israel. But you know that
in the Old Testament, Jehovah of Hosts,
who's the maker of Israel, who's the God
of all the earth, he is their husband.
And then you go on and say, "You, the
son of man, Lord of the Sabbath, who do
you think you are?" See, he's already
setting forth his divine identity. And
if you don't believe it, just go back
earlier because here earlier, this is
all in the same chapter. Christ as the
son of man has the power to forgive sins
and he proves it by healing the
paralytic so that you may know that the
son of man has authority on honor to
forgive sins I'm going to heal this man
now brother can I take a few minutes
unpacking please do brother please do
now you caught it this is all that
chapter yep same chapter okay now let me
why do I want to take a few minutes to
unpack this watch
it so we're going to now break it down
Watch. Watch what Jesus does. He does
the things that the Old Testament
attributes to Jehovah, not a creature.
Watch. We're going to set it up, but I
need you guys to follow. All
right. I got to go over here. I will
surely follow follow him. I love him. I
love him. And where he goes, I'll I
shouldn't sing, right? Because you were
making fun of my singing last night
because you're hating. He caused me to
run, brother. He caused me to run, man.
All right. Well, here now watch. Any I'm
not trying to hug the time, brother.
Honestly, I'm not. But I'm trying to
make a No, no, no, brother. I got stuff
to I We We're both doing this together.
I'm telling the audience, I don't want
them to think that I'm trying to take
over. This is needed. Now, when we
combine these together in context here,
Mark
2-12, when Jesus saw their faith, he
said to the paralyzed man, "Son, your
sins are forgiven." Yep. Now, some
teachers of law were sitting there
thinking to themselves, why does this
fellow talk like that? He's blaspheing.
Who can forgive sins but God alone? Now,
watch the three things attributed to
Christ. Immediately Jesus knew in his
spirit. Amazing. He says in his spirit
because if you read Romans 1:3, Romans
9:5, when you want to talk about the
human nature of Christ or human nature,
it'll say according to the
flesh. Guys, I want you to zero in here.
Mark is clear to tell you that Jesus
knew this by virtue of his spirit in his
spirit. Why? John 4:24 says, "The divine
nature is spirit." When the New
Testament wants to talk about Christ
humanity, Romans 1:3, Christ was the
seed of David according to the flesh.
Yep. Humanity. Romans 9:5 according to
the flesh he is of Israel. But when you
want to talk about divinity, Jesus knew
in his spirit because John 4:24 says God
is spirit. So here you see the two
natures. Divine nature is spirit. Human
nature is flesh. So how did he know
this? By virtue of
divinity, Jesus knew in his spirit that
this was what they were thinking in
their hearts. Note, they didn't
verbalize this. They were thinking this
in their hearts. He knew by virtue of
his divine nature, they were thinking
this in their hearts. And he said to
them, why are you thinking these things?
Which is easier to say to this paralyzed
man, your sins are forgiven. Or to say,
get up, take your man, and walk. Now,
obviously, if I say to William, if he's
paralyzed, your sins are forgiven, you
can't prove or disprove that, right?
That's not accessible to senses. But if
he's paralyzed and I say, "Hey, get up."
And he doesn't get up, I'm going to
humiliate myself. Yep. So, understand
what Jesus is saying. I'm going to do
something you can confirm with your
senses. I'm going to heal him
physically. You're going to see it, hear
it, touch it. To now convince you, I can
do the thing which you cannot verify
with your senses, that I have the power
to forgive sins. But I want you to know
that the son of man has authority on
earth to forgive sins. There's that son
of man phrase. There you go. So he said
to them, I tell you to the man, get up,
take your mat, go home. He got up, took
his mat, walked out in full view of them
all. This amaze everyone and they praise
God saying we have never seen anything
like this. So note Jesus forgives sins.
He knows what's in the hearts of men and
heals
diseases. Watch it. So much for that
book having a low christologology,
brother. Exactly. Now watch here. Psalm
103 2:4. Praise the Lord Yahwa my soul.
Forget not all his benefits. Who
forgives all your sins and heals all
your diseases. Yeah. Two things Jesus
did. Who redeems your life from the pit?
According to Mark 10:45, Alex, Jesus
says, Mark 10:45, for even the son of
man did not come to be served. Notice
son of man, but to serve and offer his
life as a ransom for many. So Christ
forgives sins and mark, heals diseases,
and redeems souls from the pit. But what
else does Jesus do that's ascribed to
God?
Psalm 44:21 would not God have
discovered it what we do since he knows
the secrets of the heart finally here
first kings 8:39 Solomon praying to God
then hear from heaven your dwelling
place
forgive Jesus forgave yep and act deal
with everyone according all they do
since you know their hearts you alone
you alone know every human heart hold on
Jesus like God forgives sins. Jesus like
God knows the hearts of men. Jesus like
God heals diseases. And that's Mark 2
and reference him to being the son of
man. The same Mark where Jesus says he's
the
bridegroom, which is what God is. He's
the husband of Israel, right? Micah
7:18-19. Who is a God like you? There is
no God like you who pardons sin,
forgives transgression. Jesus does that.
But in the same chapter where Jesus says
he's the bridegroom, even though Isaiah
54:5 says God is the husband, then the
same chapter where he, the son of man,
who not only forgives sins, he's the
Lord of the Sabbath. Get up. Give it up,
Alex. Mark is not your friend.